hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I just check it it on yeah
see you now you're weeks go and how's
your week going do you have somebody
running a [ __ ] jackhammer right
outside your house that's what I got can
hear it non-stop it's like the guy
nodded out with his foot on the gas
pedal however you use it needs to be a
lot quieter you know what that probably
is it's probably my [ __ ] neighbor and
he went out and he bought him he rented
a jackhammer you know take up his
[ __ ] driveway you know got a quote
one of those you knows people just so
[ __ ] cheap it doesn't even make sense
I'm a nice guy wanna he wanted 15
$20,000 I could do it for 600 bucks sing
you know your vet your veterinarian
neighbors out there with a [ __ ]
fisher-price construction hat on with
you a [ __ ] rented jackhammer Jesus
Christ what the [ __ ] are they takin up
over there I will tell you this I have
never seen remodeling in my [ __ ] life
the way it's done out here right yup
maybe just in general I think all those
MTV Cribs it's like look I've done a
bunch of [ __ ] to my house but I had
cloth wiring and [ __ ] galvanized pipe
in the wall what the [ __ ] are they doing
I can hear it I just don't know where it
is let me open the window you guys got
to get the full effect of this [ __ ]
thing I mean I mean I'm so old on vari
you say something about noise ordinances
just non-stop non [ __ ] stop I can't
say non-stop because I walked over here
to my do my podcast and it wasn't going
on and then all of a sudden was [ __ ]
happening it was funny is I didn't even
notice it I didn't even notice it till I
listen I was gonna start to record him
like wait a minute what the [ __ ] is that
noise is that some [ __ ] Do It
Yourself guy who took the you know has
to be I gotta be honest with all the
tech jobs that are out there how the
[ __ ] you end up on the other end of a
[ __ ] jackhammers beyond me who does
that job they've made him better but
back in the day people who had those
[ __ ] things they got like tremors and
[ __ ] at least I think they did I don't
know so anyway sorry the podcast is a
little bit late here it is Thursday
afternoon stilts 3:14 wherever the [ __ ]
I'm at right now right actually flew
today flew under the hood as they say
with my fog Alon you know I [ __ ] suck
at it not not at the instrument thing I
was actually really good at it I sucked
at everything else I fan shot the
defense that we shot everything else
stuck [ __ ] autos of mediocre my
[ __ ] you know approaches sucked
everything just my radio calls stunk
everything stunk about fly a couple more
times don't get the muscle memory back
but I am enjoying the the instrument
[ __ ] jesus [ __ ] christ Jesus Christ
anyway Oh [ __ ] jackhammer Jesus why
did why the fly tonight record last
night why didn't record last night was
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like what is he is
he gonna do the whole job at once I
thought I'll I can't believe Mike I'm
actually impressed with this person's
strength you know how do you know it's
not a woman oh I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know oh by the way let's get
back to Paul virzi talking about how the
Patriots are gonna win the Superbowl
you know I just assumed that the
Steelers had won a couple of games
because they're the Steelers and they
haven't won any games and then I assume
the Jets had won at least one game they
have
want any games I apologize I [ __ ] you
know I got the kid now kids only gonna
be a kid for so long so I got to make
sure I hang out with her so I'm watching
a lot of vamp arena in doc McStuffins
and all of that [ __ ] so I miss a lot of
stuff like tape games I got a couple
games I have to watch I'm gonna try to
watch as much of the Packers Eagles as I
can tonight until she comes in and tells
me that she wants to watch puppy dog
pals and then I'll be like one oh I want
to watch adult TV and then she'll just
go okay
get tears in her eyes what am I going to
say no anyway the combined record of the
three teams of New England Patriots have
played is oh and nine those three teams
have the exact same number of victories
as I do without a franchise so virzi
congratulations I told my go dude we're
not playing good teams he goes doesn't
matter like in what world doesn't it
matter
doesn't mean enough I've seen enough if
this is what they're doing the teams
that cannot even win a game imagine what
they're gonna do to the best teams in
the league come playoff time makes no
sense whatsoever Jesus Christ the Giants
are one and two [ __ ] New York man
they always have like 9 thought they got
9,000 of [ __ ] everything including
[ __ ] right what are the bills the
bills are three you know look at them
there you go that's the good team the
Bills have more wins then the [ __ ]
Giants and Jets combined isn't that
something but you know nobody New York
City respects that Buffalo theirs
they're like their [ __ ] country uncle
that shows up after somebody dies
looking to see if there's anything in
the will from my name is Buffalo belt
from the western side of state hey who
the [ __ ] is this guy him the [ __ ]
[ __ ] buffalo wings let's see what
else we got going on here
the Chiefs of three and Owen I've been
watching them Raiders are one and two
Chargers are one and two Broncos oh and
three with Joe Flacco I thought that'd
be a good fit
Ravens you look actually have the
audacity to be surprised like I know a
[ __ ] thing about pro football anymore
I don't have any I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on
anyway I just try to watch I try to
watch when I can watch I try to do what
I can do and that's that's basically
that's basically it but yeah I'm gonna
watch the little Packers Eagles and then
I'm gonna head out tonight I'm down the
Comedy Store tonight gonna be running
the new as much of the new hour as I
can't jump it around to the different
rooms and get it together because I'm
going to be at the MGM Grand in Maryland
just out of just outside of Washington
DC and the following week I'm gonna be
in North Carolina getting ready to go to
that couple shows Asheville I believe
before I go to that uh that Clemson
Florida State game speak at a Florida
State Jesus Christ they get [ __ ] wide
receivers lining up stand in the wrong
goddamn way can't pick a [ __ ] winner
this year
let me see come on Florida State if you
want to game me at Florida State
football what do you say what do you say
oh no they lost a Boise State you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I thought this was gonna be
such a great game oh no wait that was
the first one they lost to Boise Boise
State then they lost to Virginia and
then they beat Louisiana Monroe Monroe
Louisiana Monroe
there you go turning around they scored
45 points on those bumps only beaten by
one point let's look at the highlight
let me see what I'm up but you know what
I might do just as a [ __ ] joke I
might I might Barry I might [ __ ] bury
the goddamn how come I can't hit [ __ ]
you because it's an
advertisement I might [ __ ] bury the
Clemson Tigers so I can enjoy that game
and actually be nervous and feel like
there's gonna be a goddamn game like
[ __ ] they need to score 63 I don't get
it man what the [ __ ] happened to these
Florida State's always good till they
got kick a field goal Oh bill now you
know what it is Central Florida
I think Central Florida is starting to
take all their [ __ ] players everybody
wants to go there and [ __ ] being
those crazy games down there maybe is
that what it is look at this they went
up 14 nothing against Louis University
of Louisiana Monroe then what happened I
mean look at those [ __ ] helmets
they're just some basic white helmet you
know like some Randy Moss guys gonna
come out of this thing so they were up
21 to [ __ ] nothing and 145 44 I'm
burying that game I'll probably still
lose I don't give a [ __ ] anyway I had a
great last couple nights just running my
hour and all that [ __ ] and last
night I had a buddy in town we hung out
just telling stories like way back in
the day you know all the dumb [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] rooms we used to doing all
it was like the best time one of those
people that's like aging gracefully you
don't I mean just like kind of likes
being an older guy those at them it's
just a weird thing because they never
really talked about this cuz it's all
about the young people and what the [ __ ]
they're into which by the way you know
something I just you know you know when
you buy a [ __ ] suit and then it comes
with the garment bag and it just takes
up all this [ __ ] space and I don't
understand it so I finally just you know
I don't know what I just brought him to
Goodwill you know I was gonna bring it
to homeless people so they could somehow
cut four holes in it and [ __ ] have a
giant onesie zip up just figured they
deserve more dignity than that so I just
brought it to [ __ ] Goodwill right
and it finally dawned on me what
[ __ ] fashion is all fashion fashion
is just totally geared on making you
feel stupid because your pants in your
shirt are not cut the same way as
everybody else's
you know like in the [ __ ] 1800's
pants were like whatever the [ __ ] you
could sew together right your
grandmother in the goddamn log cabin put
a button on it or you know a zipper you
know [ __ ] overalls whatever the hell
they had they made their own goddamn
clothes and I was sitting I was looking
at all these [ __ ] suits I had over
the years of doing talk shows and [ __ ] I
still came up in the era when you had to
wear a suit when you did a late night
show when he did stand-up and he didn't
have to but it was encouraged and I'm
looking at all these suits I always like
anytime I get a late night talk show war
suit I always lost money because you
just get paid the standard amount
because they look at it like you're
going on there to promote something so
everybody gets paid the same whether
they're Brad Pitt or some stupid
comedian like me doing five minutes to
stand-up so but you don't want to look
like a bum because the host is coming
out with like a [ __ ] you know $2,000
suit on so you can't go out there with
the Anderson little suit that you wear
to the prom to it a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
two semesters right so I would always
lose but you know people always say yeah
but you know what you got this great
suit you know if a vent comes up a
private a corporate or something like
that but that but all right great I got
this great suit well it never came up
and now they're like they like grossly
out of style I have something that I
paid like 1500 bucks for it it's just
completely out of style and it's just
like why the [ __ ] did they do that what
they have to do in fashion is basically
every couple years they have to change
the colors and the style under this
whole guise of creativity it isn't it's
just to make you feel like a do
she's still wearing the old [ __ ] right
you're still wearing baggy jeans but
baggy jeans have now gone back to being
skinny jeans with like the [ __ ] still
hanging off your ass you can't even take
your [ __ ] skinny jeans that you had
which were just called [ __ ] jeans
that were put in the dryer too many
times when I was a kid you can't go back
to wearing those things because those
are now dad jeans it's it's you know but
if they're around like long enough but
if you grow like a mustache then you can
wear you can wear what you had what was
like 30 years old because then it's
considered ironic and actually some sort
of style it's all [ __ ] and then you
look at the [ __ ] I was at this comedy
store I was just looking there's this
big advertisement on what used to be
called the the Rock and Roll Hilton
everything was rock and roll rock and
roll Ralph's rock and roll Denny's
[ __ ] rock and roll the rock and roll
Hilton this place was Led Zeppelin used
to stay it's the one with Robert Plant
is looking at La like you know saying
he's like yeah like I'm psyched to
[ __ ] be here I can't believe how much
ass I'm gonna get here and for some
reason and a hammer of the gods
they said that he yelled I'm a golden
golden God which you know he didn't you
know John Bonham used to [ __ ] ride
his drive his cars up and down the
[ __ ] sunset like 80 miles an hour and
then they'd pull him over and he'd be so
excited about the car they wouldn't give
him a ticket because he'd just be
talking about the [ __ ] car and he was
John Bonham so anyway on the side of
that now they got this giant giant
advertisement for one of these high-end
[ __ ] designers that III that I
wouldn't even know who the [ __ ] they
were if I didn't have a wife it's not
easy saying all wrong it's not it's not
guess it's not and they probably laugh
at guess it guess is probably low rent
for these [ __ ] Instagram people no I
don't know if it's em as I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is but I'm looking at
the thing
the pit was this way I saw the picture I
forget where the picture was but like
fashion is this this when they pick out
models now it's just the combination of
like it's always super skinny no matter
what they're picking they can these
these these women are not allowed to eat
right so they kind of go with like weird
and I'm going like I'm looking at go why
do they always pick such weird-looking
[ __ ] people
and then I'm like no you know what it is
I take in me and everybody else takes
like hacky photos you know I mean they
always have like some weird [ __ ]
theme and it's just like unless they
were just mocking a selfie or mocking a
family photo they have to do something
differently and I realized that when it
comes to taking pictures I'm like that
guy who tells jokes at the office at the
water bubbler and thinks he's as funny
as a stand-up comedian
it's like when I take I do the picture
version of that you know the smile the
thumbs-up pointing at the person next to
you the peace sign you know and then my
favorite the boyband will you put your
finger up like Shh like we're doing
something quiet we're doing something
scandalous but you can take a picture of
us while we do it I realize yeah I live
in that world of photography so I don't
know I guess I'm saying I appreciate the
pictures and the people that they pick
in fashion although would be nice if
they might let them eat more but the
[ __ ] clothing is it's just up it's a
it's a bunch of [ __ ] you know Brown
is the new black Black's the new orange
orange the news is [ __ ] you you know
what it is is human beings aren't
morphing we've still got two arms with
two legs and these [ __ ] are out
of ideas and the guy yachts and they got
boats you know and they bought Islands
whether they want to [ __ ] boys on them
whatever the [ __ ] these super-rich
people are doing and they need the money
to keep coming in so what they got to do
is get the best looking people on the
planet be wearing the new stupid [ __ ]
cut of clothes that they have so some
[ __ ]
me as a closet full of suits then ain't
worth [ __ ]
I had a [ __ ] way or suit to something
the other day and I'm going to the
closet I was like wow none of these look
good anymore it's the stupidest [ __ ]
ever you normally just I'm gonna start
renting you know what I'm gonna buy a
tuxedo that's the way you do it even
that no they change up the [ __ ]
tuxedos these [ __ ] [ __ ] do you
realize do you realize how [ __ ] crazy
that is like how that's actually adding
to global warming you know and all of
this [ __ ] it's actually hastening the
demise of our possibly of our ability to
live on this [ __ ] planet is some
[ __ ] douche who likes rail-thin women
and makes his [ __ ] money off a
[ __ ] design and clothes has to keep
changing it up so we can keep that
mountain of coke to pay off whatever he
needs to pay off of to have his weird
[ __ ] sex parties is this true or just
or do I just not like shopping or is it
the [ __ ] jackhammer I don't know I
have no [ __ ] idea but I can tell you
this you know it's really when you sit
there and you look at these [ __ ]
people in fashion how [ __ ] skinny
they are at first I felt bad for them
but then I was just like you know what
at my age to be in the shape that I'm in
I have to eat the way they're probably I
have to probably eat less than they do
there's still in the 20s and they're
also always like 9 feet tall big stupid
giraffe looking people you know [ __ ]
legs the size of a pretzel rod with that
giant [ __ ] Bill Walton foot you know
at the end of it
um anyway that was just something I was
thinking about the other day so I got it
some event coming up and I gotta wear a
[ __ ] suit and I just went through my
head of the suits that I owned all the
way back to like I don't know oh four oh
five and I got to be honest you know a
well-made suit is gonna last a long time
do you know go to tonight's show of
course you don't you young it was this
guy's name was Johnny Carson you know he
did a lot of things of this business and
he actually at one point had a line of
his own suits and there was a point on
that show where he just stopped giving a
[ __ ] and was wearing towards the end the
[ __ ] jackets that this guy was
[ __ ] wearing and I wasn't in you know
I wasn't into their habit - that's a
[ __ ] quote from one of those dice
specials way back in the day they have a
dish
haberdashery or something right he used
to come out wearing [ __ ] suits that
were just astoundingly out of style I
mean I kind of noticed like in the late
80s he was still wearing [ __ ] from the
early 70s late 60s these crazy cuts
crazy colors and that type of [ __ ] and I
used it was hilarious I used to watch
the show was when I was working in a
warehouse I watched it for the comedians
and then it was another gut in one of
the suits who worked at this place
software company I worked with he used
to watch it you know for whatever the
the panel and all of that type of stuff
but being a suit himself he knew a
little bit about suits and he and I
would be talking about the comic I saw
and all he would be doing is talking
about the jacket the Johnny Carson did
you see what the [ __ ] that guy was
wearing I remember one time he came out
he had a suit it had like you know the
double cut in the back that mudflap
which i think was in somewhere around
the time Gerald Ford took
/ from Richard Nixon I just realized
nobody gives a [ __ ] about this because
this is like from the early 70s and I
talked to somebody the other day I
brought up Johnny Carson to somebody who
was 34 almost 35 and she goes who's that
oh my god it stopped oh thank Christ all
right now now watch me be in a better
mood did I ever tell you how much I
liked Johnny Carson suits I liked him
better than the comedian's he did get a
little noise out of your [ __ ] life
turns around you hope goddamn attitude I
finally committed to rehab in my second
shoulder I was so goddamn depressed that
I had to go through this [ __ ] crap
again with this thing that I as always I
blow off an injury for a year I'm like
yeah I'll just do an organic sort of not
do anything and maybe it'll heal itself
I'm doing it now I had to join a gym
with a [ __ ] pool you know waiting for
the old ladies to finish their laps all
I can think of it's just like if she
dies in there right now does that mean I
don't get to swim is there enough
chlorine in here that by the time they
fish her out her deadness won't be on my
side of the pool feels everybody
do you experience stress yes or have
anxiety yes or chronic pain yes or have
trouble sleeping at least once a week
what you say
what is feels feels is premium CBD
delivered directly to your doorstep this
has really been helping my shoulder by
the way what this feels do feels
naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness it does
everything but shut that brought up in
your life or dude or they lose
progressive he's bringing the feels
train around okay easy to take place a
few drops of feels under your tongue and
feel the difference within minutes real
he feel funny that would be if your wife
was nagging you and as she's
that you just took out some fields and
you dropped a couple of drops under your
tongue why are you doing that is that
because of me no man I got no problem
with you man you groovy oh yeah wait I'm
not supposed to actually could get you
high it doesn't get you high everybody
real human support new new to CBD fields
offers a free CBD hotline and text
message support to help guide your
personal experience this is for older
people what is it heroin feel better
naturally feels works naturally to help
you feel better there's no high no
hangover no addiction okay membership
join the fields community man to get
feels delivered to your door every month
you'll save money on every order and you
can purchase or cancel anytime
become a member today by going to feels
calm / / and you'll get 50 percent off
your first order with free shipping
that's f e a LS man dot-com / / to
become a member and get 50% off
automatically take taken off your first
order with free shipping feels calm / /
Fe ALS calm / / alright oh Jesus I'm due
for a new shipment from these guys
butcher box butcher box you know not
everyone has convenient access to
high-quality meat well ladies you hit
the treadmill and uh maybe you can get
that dream guy it could be it could be
hard to find 100% grass-fed / finished
beef free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork my favorite my for the second
I see butcher box that's all I think of
is the heritage breed pork that's how
delicious is or wild-caught salmon you
don't know what it's gonna do wild
caught salmon at the grocery store my
favorite is the heritage breed pork
every month butcher bucks ships a
curated selection of high-quality meat
right to your home all meat is free of
antibiotics and added hormones each box
has 9 to 11 pounds of meat enough for 24
individual size meals or a couple of
sliders if you know if you got giantism
you can customize your box or go with
one of theirs either way you get exactly
what you want with butcher box you get
the highest quality meat meat around for
just six dollars per meal and they this
is the worst read ever I'm just like
[ __ ] not going fast and I'm not going
slow let's regroup and they even have
free shipping nationwide except Alaska
and Hawaii right now butcher box is
offering new members ground beef for
life that's two pounds of ground beef
and every box for the life of your
scripts Christian of their subscription
plus $20 off their first box just go to
butcher box com / / or enter the promo
code burr at checkout what do you mean
or mine isn't it and that's butcher
box.com / / or enter the promo code
burrow checkout if you didn't do it
already okay well there you go that's
where you get your meat man I'm hooking
you up man alright so who do you like
tonight the two and one Eagles against
the three and OH Packers Aaron Rodgers
celebrating the incredible protection he
got during the last game how about the
[ __ ] Patriots sign in that Eagles
quarterback Jesus Christ did we [ __ ]
put our backup out there one goddamn
play
he throws a pick six go [ __ ] yourself
there isn't what we do here it's not
what we do here Jesus Christ I can't
imagine the pressure a plane for Bill
Belichick I mean that's why he's great
that's why he's great but I'll tell you
right now if every time I [ __ ] threw
a pick six in my life and they brought
in a replacement I don't know where I'd
be having said that because I get so
much of my identity about Who I am by
how much the football team from the
general area of where I lived growing up
I'm glad he does it you know do you got
that in you do you got that Bill
Belichick in you to go out there and
just [ __ ] tell some kid hey kid we
gave you a shot at your dream we gave
you one shot and you [ __ ] blew it so
we're bringing in somebody else who
might possibly take your dream it's up
to you but just know you've already
[ __ ] this up anyways alright I don't
know what else to tell you I stayed up
to like [ __ ] 2:00 in the morning last
night telling stories story after
[ __ ] story after goddamn story just
having the greatest [ __ ] time I don't
know I can't do it though man Jesus
Christ I feel like I'm [ __ ] hungover
I've got five hours sleep you're not
supposed to do that but you know at my
age it's actually dangerous I was
reading about it you know especially for
gingers you know I know we feel less
pain than you weaker people out there
that's because we've been teased so much
in life that getting a filling without
anesthetic is nothing compared to
outdoor recess first grade through fifth
grade that's funny the next time some
woman tells me about the pain of
childhood labor childhood labor doesn't
come out right child labor
childhood labor Jesus Christ oh the pain
of childbirth that's what I was trying
to say I'll interrupt her in middle hey
just look at me I'm a redhead we have a
higher threshold for pain than anybody
else I'm sure for you as a brunette
blonde whatever the hell it is you are I
can't see in this light in the light of
my imagination okay I don't want to hear
it okay
I can take more than you so if you guys
learn anything from this podcast
know this I just literally cut myself
off I was trying to hit the button to
see the
I know this okay no matter how hard you
hit me it would hurt more if I didn't
have red hair
see it's I'm not saying it wouldn't hurt
that's the loophole so when I start
crying just know that you you'd be
crying more okay and that's my comeback
if you're a redhead of anybody beats you
up it's like the worst [ __ ] comeback
ever don't say that people don't say
that all right that's the podcast
everybody I was just a quick one just
checking in on you you know you probably
driving home right now you got one more
[ __ ] day right
you got one Monday here's a goal for
this weekend all right don't take any
[ __ ] but you don't need to take from
whoever the [ __ ] you're in relationship
with all right just give him a look and
when they say well what's that look for
just go you know no I don't know and
then you go yeah well maybe you should
then go back to watching whatever the
[ __ ] it is you want to watch do that and
try to have some of your paycheck left
over come Monday huh
what are you gonna do when the zombies
show up and you can't give them any cash
I mean that's all that really after they
just can't express it okay that's it
my prediction tonight is I don't know
who's gonna win how about that where is
the game let's see here this is how the
typical [ __ ] gambler Green Bay
Packers it's not about winning or losing
it's just about the anxiety it's just
about having some action on the game
Packers verse eagles predictions what
what are people saying well Stephen a
predicts the Eagles beat the Packers I
would love to listen to that but I'm
kind of chill right now I don't need
that guy screaming at me because I know
there's gonna be another white dude who
picks the exact opposite of him and then
he's gonna start yelling and then just
gonna start yelling each oh no he
doesn't work or skip bayless anymore
does he
all right Thursday Night Football odds
he goes first Packers all right Eagles
versus Packers picks best predictions
from experts
whose twenty seven and four on green
baize game against the spread all right
I don't know wide receiver Sivir Alshon
Jeffrey is at Elgin or Alshon Jeffrey
Jesus Christ you know when I was a kid
it was Bob bill you know when black guys
were like Harold and Leon [ __ ] you can
pronounce now like white kids are named
it like are named after like B and C
level cities there's my son Jacksonville
Jacksonville will you tell Fayetteville
to get off the goddamn Davenport and
tight in Dallas go ahead I look at right
there the second one named after a
[ __ ] City a b-level City Dallas they
think they're in a level City it's
because they're not well-traveled are
expected to return to the field for
Thursday Night Football between the
Philadelphia Eagles ant that Green Bay
Packers at Lambeau Field I'm getting
excited for there's any better than
[ __ ] a night game at Lambeau Field
[Music]
all right she got me but other than that
for the Eagles the return of Jeffery
there's an old school name and got go
dirt goe D ERT couldn't come at a better
time both pass catchers missed Ally
I don't give a [ __ ] I just want to start
reading more [ __ ] names here it's
hilarious let's look up look the
Seahawks wear their old [ __ ] white
coach his name's Pete alright let's
let's see
craziest names in sports all right let's
see here we go
I mean rusty Kuntz has to be the but we
ought when I was a kid we all thought it
was rusty [ __ ] all right here we go
fifteen of the weirdest and funniest
names in sport all right just give me
the list
there's somebody named booth Posner that
has to be a nickname there's no way that
somebody named a kid booth john-paul
baza
nicknames don't count Ron tug nut that's
an old-school one Dick Trickle
old-school
Larry Playfair I always said there was a
great name Larry Playfair and he was
what probably a piece of [ __ ] not a
piece of [ __ ] tough guy or something
Milton Bradley bake McBride guy whimper
wonderful terrific Monds jr. most people
be astonished to find out that there are
three wonderful Mons out there wonderful
terrific Monds jr. was born in Fort
Pierce Florida in 1952 and what do you
call him as a nickname one yeah one
school Dick Butkus well these are old
school come on people
rich cisely rest his soul did this bit
years ago I'm hip stubby clap raiser
shines God sham God Tommy Gunn Austin
Powers no rusty no rusty [ __ ] Kuntz all
right
craziest sports names in I'd say modern
sports come on let me see these [ __ ]
DeWanna Bonner the brick house Ferguson
I always liked that name rusty cuts made
the list there it is
haha Clinton dicks D'Brickashaw DeWanna
Pete Lacock dick Pole dick Pole of Wow
Richard well what the [ __ ] of people
thinking if your last name's Pole why
would you name your kid dick
all right that's it I've run out of [ __ ]
to talk about all right enjoy the music
and then we got a bonus greatest hits
episode of Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
enjoy it
have a good time watching the Packers
Eagles are learning a second language
whatever you going to do with those
three hours of your life all right Ronny
Chang taping is special for all thing
with all things commies I should say
this Friday night and Glendale get you
get your tickets get down there I'm
gonna try to get down and give them some
support tomorrow night if I can get my
ass out there that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great weekend
jeez all right long-distance hiking the
last week I mentioned that I went on a
hike and we just kept going and going
like [ __ ] not realizing that we had
to walk back hiking is not like a
treadmill you don't just get to step off
and be like oh I'm still despite the
fact I walked for an hour I am still
only you know ten paces from my [ __ ] the
parking lot in my car we ended up going
on like an 11 mile hike and it was
exhausting to say the least so this
person is writing about long-distance
hiking another great old man thing to do
yoga hockey ice hockey and hiking you
know all right hey Bill I've been
listening to your podcast long enough to
know that you love hiking you hate
getting fat and you get easily annoyed
by day-to-day [ __ ] I really think
you'd enjoy backpacking out Jesus
backpacking I know it's awesome but can
you call it something else
backpacking I just feel like I'm [ __ ]
waiting for a bus picking my nose about
ready to get this [ __ ] kicked out of me
hey you guys want to go backpacking it's
a pack you put on your back and you go
backpacking or long-distance hiking okay
let's call it that it's a really a
long-distance hiking freaks me out
because that
at that point you've walked long enough
to run into something that can maul you
to death / rip your face off or at the
very least just sort of bite your throat
until it stops feeling the pulse you
know start getting into that next weight
class of animals I don't know you know
mountain lions black bear grizzly bear
[ __ ] anaconda whatever exotic pet
that somebody let loose that has no
natural enemy that is now taking over
the forest long disor long distance
hiking it's really it's really freeing
to walk away from civilization for a
week or more with the solid pair of
boots and everything you needs strapped
to your back dude [ __ ] that yeah mole
man or woman that I am I can't [ __ ]
deal with that I get scared I get I get
freaked the [ __ ] out I'd have to be out
there with somebody who knew what they
were doing who had a gun automatic to
not even semi-automatic I need something
that I could spray in the general
direction of the sound I just heard and
you know if we kill a couple of
backpackers there's no one else around
burying them is optional I would say
leave them above ground because they'll
get picked away a lot quicker then
people will find their clothes
I guess the bones would be there that's
creepy
see what happens when you go out in the
wilderness so you start [ __ ] talking
about [ __ ] like that I live in a suburb
okay there's plenty of people to shoot
and I never think of doing it they're
right out there right [ __ ] out there
I never think of shooting them all of a
sudden you get me backpacking or
long-distance hiking and I'm trying to
think out of bury bodies alright every
time I finish a long hike I come back
looking healthier and leaner and feeling
refreshed yeah cuz you're out there
eating berries wiping your ass with
[ __ ] pine cones that's that that's
why you have that peculiar look on your
face no matter how much you eat on the
trail you're guaranteed to lose weight
if you spend six hours a day hiking with
a 35 pound backpack there's no need to
limit yourself
two salads and juice I can't tell you
how many times I've had older day hikers
look at my backpack and tell me they
wish they had done more backpacking when
they were able to it's a really unique
experience experience out there on your
own yeah I bet it is well what can you
please write back and tell me what you
do about animals man because I'm telling
you right now I'm not doing this you
know the only way I would do this is I
was in a [ __ ] platoon and we all had
machine guns just in case I missed
anyways oh here he goes he's gonna calm
me down and it isn't nearly as dangerous
or as difficult as people make it out to
be if you stay on the trail you'll
usually run across another hiker every
few hours oh that's comforting that's
comforting every couple hours I can run
into Johnny Appleseed but during the
other hour and 15 minutes I'm on my own
alright now you're running that usually
run into another hike or every few hours
that can help you if you get hurt and
bears mountain lions and all those other
beasts kill a lot fewer people than Los
Angeles traffic accidents do well I used
to do a bit on that well obviously
because the [ __ ] you know that
there's you're running into one person
every two hours sir let's do the math
here okay here's the deal there's like
seven million people in Los Angeles okay
you can't [ __ ] go anywhere without
running into like a thousand [ __ ]
people out here you're somewhere where
you walk every two hours and run into
one human being so obviously I can
guarantee you if those lions and
mountain lions were down here
the death rate would be through the
[ __ ] roof alright this is the guy
this is what he says - he goes just keep
your food away from your tent and you'll
be fine do you understand sir that
you're telling me to do something where
if I'm too near my food supply I could
possibly get eaten to death you want me
to leave my living room
you know why can't I just sit on my back
porch listen I would love I would love
to to go hiking like that I really would
but I cannot get past no I don't think
you should be able to get past it that
there's that type of [ __ ] is out there
all right and if you get mauled to death
as a stand-up comedian you really would
just looking for trouble weren't you
that's you know somebody just asked me
to do a cruise
to do stand-up on a cruise and I I told
them I wasn't gonna do it and they said
why not and I said because I'm terrified
of the ocean okay that's why I don't I I
respect it the ocean is not the ocean it
is the ocean but it's it's literally
you're talking about its
outer space on earth that's what it is
okay you can't breathe in it you're nuts
you can't be in it if you're in it too
long you're either gonna get hypothermia
or something's gonna come up and take a
bite out of here to see if you're edible
or are you gonna drown those are your
three [ __ ] options and I know what
you're thinking dude Cruise is a safe
man you're out there on this big [ __ ]
boat yeah and until you're not until
you're not and then you proceeded to die
one of these slowest most terrifying
[ __ ] deaths that there is treading
water in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
and somebody's gonna die no matter how
fast they can [ __ ] get you out there
somebody is gonna die and people follow
I [ __ ] with did one cruise in my life
and I could not I couldn't get past the
fact that I was on something that the
second it [ __ ] shits the bed and I
know you guys think that you oh I've
been on cruises
go [ __ ] yourself I talked to the band
that was on this cruise ship for [ __ ]
years and they told me stories over a
little [ __ ] plate of jello late at
night those awful cruise desserts some
poor excuse for [ __ ] I also I don't
like [ __ ] going out there and all of
a sudden it's maritime laws and this
douchebag who didn't even run for office
is now telling me what the it's whatever
he says goes with his stupid-ass [ __ ]
outfit go [ __ ] yourself
they told me stories okay they told me
they told me enough [ __ ] stories
about food poisoning about [ __ ] backing
up about one engine not working and now
they're going half-speed and then they
don't make it to all the cities and then
they make up [ __ ] about hurricanes and
then they have [ __ ] trust me people
having medical issues and having to be
[ __ ] helicoptered off and flown as
quickly as humanly possible not to the
best possible hospital to the nearest
one all right and you're going on a
cruise they go all over the [ __ ]
world and they go by a bunch of [ __ ]
countries that you wouldn't want to
[ __ ] get em I've have a goddamn
hangnail in but all of a sudden they're
the closest one and that's where the
[ __ ] you're going dole hey dr. Harry
hack it off [ __ ] that [ __ ] that alright
[ __ ] combines stand-up comedy in
Waterworld I'm not doing it
alright so that's the thing about I
would absolutely love to go backpacking
I would love to do that I would love to
go up [ __ ] mountains I would love to
do that it's way better than going to
the gym I understand 100% what you're
talking about but dude that [ __ ] will
you run into a bear mama bear and it
just turns around and just runs at you
3540 miles an hour you basically and
you're sitting there
hearing this this beast like trees
getting out of the [ __ ] way it's this
thing is just coming flying down the
[ __ ] hill at you and you're running
knowing you're gonna get caught and
you're hearing your stupid pots and pans
calling clanking together and all you're
trying to do is just get out in front of
your friend so he's the one that goes
down and so you can live knowing for the
rest of your life what your strategy did
killed your friends here in his cries
boom
whatever the what is the sound of having
your face ripped off now I like to lose
weight like the next guy
Jesus gonna go out there with your beard
be a [ __ ] bear mace [ __ ] all of that
bears mountain lions poisonous snakes
what about if you just and then all the
[ __ ] varmints out there I love that
word because that you sent me Sam's the
only person I ever heard use it and when
I found out it was actually a credible
word and not something made up I
absolutely love that word farm it's you
know badgers Wolverines Bobcats people
look at Bobcats like they're no big deal
here we gotten scratched by a [ __ ]
house cat how bad that that thing can
[ __ ] you up with it's a little ass
[ __ ] pause alright you you want a
goddamn Lynx jumping on you going to
[ __ ] town cuz it's bored or you
freaked it out or you came near to near
something that had peed on and you have
no [ __ ] idea that's another thing
dude you're in their world this guy
actually actually respected the fact
that I said I'm not doing it but I
honestly he I think he thought it was
pretty peculiar that I wouldn't do
stand-up on a cruise I just jumped
subjects sorry and and I was waiting for
him to ask me why and I would just be
like well you know would you do a
podcast you know in and on a boat in a
lake that's full of [ __ ] alligators
I mean you can blow okay we're on the
boat everything's [ __ ] fine but it's
really is just an unnecessary risk that
you take goes all the way back to that
[ __ ] Saints fan
he got off easy that same [ __ ] guy
put that guy with his jersey with his
video camera camera walking up to a mama
bear screaming who day who day and all
that type of [ __ ] he's worried about
getting spit in his face he would have
bare saliva all around his [ __ ] neck
ah Jesus Christ I've actually thought
about that like what I do if a bear was
running right at me I just wished that I
would have the wherewithal to run right
at it like you know if a shark was
coming at me swim right at it and as
quickly as you can shove your [ __ ]
head in there and get it over with
that is the only [ __ ] strategy what
are you gonna climb a tree things gonna
go right up that tree do you ever see
that YouTube video of those guys sitting
in the tree hunting that bear and all of
a sudden the bear just literally runs up
the tree next to him and is like like I
don't know seven feet above them on the
tree next to him leaning out sniffing at
them trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
they are and I love how the Bears just
instinct would stink Foligno it's just
like like with that bear eight feet
above you that's like when you're in a
the upper deck of a stadium you know and
you're shit-faced and you get into it
with somebody two rows behind you they
automatically have the advantage because
they're punching down right you're gonna
lose that fight you're gonna fall on
your back you're probably gonna break
your ankle something's gonna get twisted
it's this guy's punching down on you now
just imagine it was a bear that was the
situation these people learned you got
to check out that video this [ __ ]
bear it was on the ground and they're
whispering and their little fatigues
looking at this thing and then this
thing I don't know how it found him you
just heard
and that was it over this thing was all
of a sudden not on the floor of the
forest 20 feet down it was now eight
feet above them sniffing at them like oh
is that a food source Jesus dude you
really just hit on like two people today
hit on two tremendous fears I have being
alone in the [ __ ] wilderness and and
and being out to sea [ __ ] both of those
although I want to hear the stories if
you do it you know not if you went on a
cruise I don't give a [ __ ] going out
there eating jello with your date rape
drug [ __ ] weirdo you know to go see
the reunion of Wham long-distance hiking
follow up alright here we go a few weeks
ago you asked for advice on how to deal
with animals in the wilderness most
people that get mauled either left food
in there oh yeah that's why I have this
massive fear about going into the woods
and accidentally stumbling upon a mama
bear with their Cubs or a mountain lion
I'm always on a trail and to the left or
the right of me is a higher like like
cliff and the thing is just sitting
there you know you know when they sit
there and they put their head down and
their [ __ ] shoulder and back muscles
go like [ __ ] like if they were in a
muscle competition like that would be
like the Schwarzenegger of like stance
they put the head down you know what I'm
saying just waiting to pounce on me this
is what the president says most people
get mauled either most people that get
mauled either left food in their tent or
tried to pose for a picture with the
animal or did some other dumb [ __ ] you
would never do but yes on very rare
occasions an animal will attack somebody
who did nothing wrong
here is my advice if that happens first
of all you did do something wrong you
ventured out into the wilderness you
left the tribe you put yourself at risk
all right I mean I guess if you're in
your backyard and there's a bear there
but if there's a bear in your backyard
you that's urban sprawl that went
he's not in your backyard you're in his
front yard there's no [ __ ] reason a
bear should be outside your house you
need to move back down towards the
village all right they're antisocial get
a hobby say hello to somebody you know
have a couple of drinks get some alcohol
courage in you and go walk up to the
pretty girl and say hello okay stop
trying to live with the [ __ ] owls
all right bears if you're attacked by a
bear you should leave your backpack on
to protect your back and use your hands
to cover your neck what about your face
usually the bear will leave after a
while but if it starts to chew on you
that's when you need to fight back oh
really what should I go with should I
set up the you know the overhand right
with a couple of jabs or should I try to
kick him in his bare balls what if it's
a woman what do I do or try to stick my
toe in its vag it's bare vag it's badge
mountain lines with mountain lions
playing dead will not work you need to
fight back right away your best chance
is to aim for the nose and eyes dude
this is [ __ ] hilarious I mean I I
think I would have this is none of this
[ __ ] work wouldn't work against Mike
Tyson's forget about a [ __ ] bear or a
mountain lion
wolves playing dead won't work in a wolf
attack either you can either climb a
tree put it in a headlock or shove your
fist down its throat I'm not joking look
it up you know what I always thought you
could do a I don't know about a wolf
I always thought against this was my you
know when I'm laying in bed and I'm
thinking about getting attacked by a
[ __ ] you know some rabid dog or
whatever if somebody's sick that dog on
me when I'm laying in bed totally
relaxed and have my wits about me and I
don't have a urine running down my leg
as I run towards my Prius like I
wouldn't real life
I my plan of attack was when the [ __ ]
dog is coming at you you stick your
forearm out and you just feed it to him
you just jam it right into his [ __ ]
mouth and right as it climbs down and it
has you you then take your other [ __ ]
forearm and you come up over the top
smash down on the top of the things neck
as you push your forearm up and you
break its neck you go BAM clap which is
the sound of a broken neck flap I'm
sorry I don't wanna make this snap noise
I don't have a twig in here that's that
was my game plan either that or just
stick your arm in there and you just you
just [ __ ] start stepping on the dog's
feet cuz dogs are kind of [ __ ] man
they'll go after you but the second you
[ __ ] do something back to you you
know what it is they don't have any
shame they don't mind going wrong and
then getting hit and then going like
they don't give a [ __ ] it's not like
other dogs they can literally do that
and then go on the other side of the
block and get laid
there's like no and they don't even
remember what just happened unless
there's still pain in their little dog
paw so um I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know what I'm talking about here these
these are all like these were all creepy
[ __ ] questions
I always felt if I was on a boat and I
saw an alligator swimming towards one of
my friends and it went by the boat or a
shark I would just try to time it where
I jump down and I just [ __ ] land
right on its head and I just figured
that that alone would so freak it out
they would leave or you know the shark
or alligators would be would be feasting
on two people that's right I'll be
worried about after the show after this
shock you know when the Sharks like what
the phew [ __ ] when it's coming
back that's why I think like sharks I
think just leave alligators are they
just seem [ __ ] relentless to me
alright killer bees here we go
with killer bees Africanized honeybees
you're supposed to run away for at least
half a mile now this I know
do not flail your arms and do not kill
one they will swarm you if you kill one
but honestly they they look just like
normal bees to me so I don't know how to
tell when you're in danger oh my god run
for a half-a-mile for [ __ ] half a
mile what's the fastest my fastest mile
I ever ran was like a 6:18 like freshman
year in high school when I weighed about
a hundred and forty something pounds and
now a buck seventy-five so I think I
could run maybe a seven minute even with
the fear just the pain is gonna offset
the adrenaline that's gonna be a long 15
minutes people Oh God can you imagine me
a balding stung up [ __ ] swollen
redhead just coming over their health
Jesus Christ what a sight alright
spiders kill almost nobody most can be
very dangerous if you catch them at the
wrong time some snake bites obviously
require immediate medical care but I
would be more afraid of lightning if I
were you so yes it can get gruesome but
these attacks are very rare absolutely I
mean I know shark attacks are very rare
but it's just like I would love to try
surfing but just you know just the fact
that you know you understand that
surfing is a sport where you're risking
getting eaten alive I mean it's just
[ __ ] I mean it's just not worth it
goddamn it it looks like
you